12 points are arranged in order around a
circle and then here come the questions
number one hey how many travelers can be
drawn with these points as vertices be
how many pairs and such triangles can be
drawn if the vertices of the two
triangles are distinct part see how it
pairs in those pairs how many will the
train goes overlap or not overlap rather
and how many will overlap okay so this
is confusing so we're going to have it
going up okay okay so the first thing
we're going to do is actually sorry
Junsu could you get the window please
the first thing we need to do is up to
get together a picture right so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to draw myself
a circle and 12 points are really easy
to do because there are 12 points on a
clock so that's that's nice and simple
there we go so here are the 12 points on
the circumference of my circle I hope
it's not very circular okay now part a
is the easiest one it's kind of like no
conditions what's so ever didn't you go
the bathroom okay I'll tell you a funny
story that's that's worse than that day
sorry right
that's a great idea thanks Nikita how
many triangles can be drawn with these
points as vertices how many triangles
can be drawing with these points as
vertices ok now let's um let's remember
you got 12.0 and to make a triangle any
triangle all you need to do is join up
three points you just have to join three
points ok so for instance you could join
up these guys that would be a triangle
or you could try that lets get a new
color you could join up these guys and
that would be a triangle ok so what I'm
trying to understand is how can i
convert this into like what is it a
permutation is it a combination is a you
know all that kind of thing so to help
us a little bit all of these are numbers
around the edge I'm going straight these
points rather i'm going to number them
that will give me some language to talk
about these things now being that i said
this was a clock why don't we start at
12 that's noon and we go one two three
all the way around there my 12 points
thank goodness I can carry now in order
to make a triangle for instance I've got
13 and 6 that made a triangle ok or 4 8
and 11 ok now quick question of those
two triangles I just there does it
matter what order I supply those numbers
in but 136 631 316 are they different or
are they the same the answer is they are
the same right so therefore am I in
permutations territory or combination
surgery combination combinations very
good order doesn't matter so that's the
first thing i want to say i might even
say for yourself hi day what I doesn't
matter so this is just like a thing from
my own head ok then when I realized ok
this is about something choose something
this is like an NCR type problem right
how many choices do I have to choose
from the answer is there 12 choices and
of those 12 us to take options of those
options I have to
83 83 right so therefore if aught it
doesn't matter I've got 12 and are three
of them I want therefore the number of
ways is just going to be tossed right
thing that's it transition that's the
number of triangles I can make what is
tossing through and someone can someone
get the calculator okay really on the
twelfth row come on I've already got
this number no I'm not ready to write ok
users to 220 okay yeah I was almost
there okay right lovely that's just a
beginning let's have like a puppy it
says how many pairs of such triangles
can be drawn if the vertices are the two
triangles are distinct okay putt be I'm
dealing with pears yeah it's a good
question i'm going to write it down then
we'll unpack it and it says the vertices
are distinct okay so I've got a couple
of triangles already on them okay you
can see I've got a one two three four
five one two three four five six points
fit down but importantly the six points
are all different to each other right
for instance I could draw over here I
could draw a triangle here like that
it's another triangle right but its
vertices are not distinct from that
first screen train-related right ivory
used one does that make sense so if i
had ones that reuse I wouldn't have six
point seven five or four or however many
so if i want the vertices distinct what
that really means is I've got to have
six points picked out does that make
sense not just three not just four or
five I have to have six does that make
sense okay so in order to get this and
this how many ways are there a lot think
about this yeah I still have 12 to
choose from but I just have to pick two
other them sorry pick six of them
now pause for a second let's just
suppose and you're going to have to do a
few of these bun work let's suppose I'd
actually picked out get rid of home I'll
get rid of no no I'm just going to draw
myself a new one to that look good I
think it's right now if I have picked
out six of them let's pick out a six
okay so I'm just going to go one two six
ok so this is one of the configurations
that I could choose right is there just
one way to pick out the number of
triangles that I'm making there's not
right in fact with these six points I
can make a whole bunch of different
triangles so the question is how many
different triangles can i make just with
these six points ok because this is all
the different sets of six points that I
can do this is really ways of picking
six vertices but now out of these
vertices I have to make my pair of
triangles ok now i'm just going to pause
for a minute I want you to think about
this before i show you the answer i have
to admit when I first had a look at this
I came up with an answer and I was like
mmm not entirely convinced the number
was different so I was like what have I
done wrong so I where I looked I wasn't
convinced and then I can visit myself of
two different ways which is how I knew
it was right that I can go from here
this is just picking the six and then
I've got to make the triangles there's a
pair of them right how would you argue
after this how many ways there are to
make a pair of triangle I'll give you
about a minute just to think it was
quite of your in mind how you would
answer this question